this is great i don't go on fat fire as
much as you do um i do it from time to
time but i don't like i don't know i
need to like add it to my feed or
whatever uh but yeah this is great 38
years old 15 million 15 million net
worth not five uh 15.8
uh and then the six million annual
income is actually the more stunning
part like i'm not surprised that a
lawyer at 40 can have 15 million in net
worth it's the 6 million in annual
income that's sort of like stunning
which makes me want to understand
this personal injury lawyer business
better like he says like you know i do
know marketing i basically just hand out
business cards plus i get referrals for
my existing clients
um but that is a ton
that is a ton of like take home from
your
like your legal practice i don't think
that's
common so i wonder what he's doing
[Music]
dude all right i have some i have
something interesting that i saw sean i
posted a link to the subreddit to this
reddit post that i saw right before i
logged into this
uh
to the podcast and i linked it to you so
basically there's this subreddit called
fat fire that i like i've sent it to you
and every once in a while you get these
amazing stories about people because
they reveal like their income and things
like that and i've been following this
lawyer he's a 38 year old explain what
fat fire is yeah so fast people don't
know what fat fire
fire stands for financially independent
retired early traditionally it's like a
movement of people who want to save like
500 000 to a million dollars and live
off of like 30 30 30 or 40 thousand
dollars a year that's not exactly what
it means but that's like traditionally
like with the stereotype fat fire means
you want to retire in early and be
financially independent but you want to
be doing it fat so you want to like you
know save like 20 million dollars or
something like that so you want to start
a company sell and retire and so it's
people who want to retire while they're
young and uh do it by still living
living lavishly and it sounds douchey
but it's actually quite interesting it's
all like entrepreneurs bankers tech
people who like work at a it's just like
rich people and which is always fun
to like be voyeuristic and so there's
this guy he's a 38 year old personal
injury lawyer
and for the past four years he's given
an update every couple of years and he
explains everything that's going on in
his business and so his background is
basically that he was a normal he went
to a good school and then worked at one
of the big law firms which is like
something that you like grind for 80
hours a week and hopefully climb your
way up and eventually you make a million
dollars a year after 10 or 15 years but
it's kind of boring and you're like kind
of like the your boss is for a
long time and it just kind of sucks and
so he goes you know what screw this a
friend of his got hurt and he goes hey
i'll represent you uh just pay me
whatever's fair and then he did and he
won and then a few other people started
coming to him just word of mouth and so
he was doing this in the evenings uh
while he was still working his main job
and after a year he quit to do his own
thing that's when his uh income from his
moonlighting became bigger than his
normal thing so fast forward now i
believe it's been about eight years
since he's been doing this so 2014 to
2022 and he's listed out his income as
well of his net worth breaking it down
by assets for every single year so in
year one it was three hundred thousand
dollars two six hundred thousand eight
hundred thousand one point two million
three million five point six million six
million six million and this year so far
three point three and it's going to be
eight million this year and that's
personal income basically he he has
these posts where he breaks down exactly
how his businesses work what his current
plan is what his growth challenges are
what his marketing is and basically he's
got like five attorneys that work for
him and he's slowly built up to that he
gets a little bit of cut of all that
they have they have 300 cases that they
do a year um
he talks about growth challenges which
is that they're struggling with the crm
they don't have a crm everything's done
manually manually and it's a lot of work
and one of his golden goals is to
automate a lot of stuff but it's
incredibly fascinating for two reasons
one
this is a sick business right like it's
like just a 37 year old smart person but
he doesn't seem like that particularly
extraordinary but he's like killing it
now he says that his net worth is
currently 5.8 million dollars
and his kids have a trust fund of 1.7
million and then secondly why this is
cool for a couple reasons one alex
hermosie had this business alex rosie
was a guest here he had this business
called gym launch where he basically
worked with gyms where he that you paid
him 20 or 30 000 and he set up your
whole crm and he set up all the
automated emails for onboarding and just
kind of set up the automation flow
someone should do that for these
personal injury attorneys this is
awesome they have way more money than
jim's and probably just as many of them
i have no idea but probably
um
i don't know what do you think about
this post this is pretty cool right
this is great i don't go on fat fire as
much as you do um i do it from time to
time but i don't like i don't know i
need to like add it to my feed or
whatever uh but yeah this is great 38
years old 15 million 15 million net
worth not five uh 15.8
uh and then the six million annual
income is actually the more stunning
part like i'm not surprised that a
lawyer at 40 can have 15 million in net
worth it's the six million in annual
income that's sort of like stunning
which makes me want to understand
this personal injury lawyer business
better like he says like you know i do
know marketing i basically just hand out
business cards plus i get referrals for
my existing clients
um but that is a ton
that is a ton of like take home from
your
like your legal practice i don't think
that's
common so i wonder what he's doing
that's uncommon like he talks about
look these cases basically like
you know it's not about more cases like
300 cases could end up being worth more
than 3 000 cases because
you you know you get paid based on the
outcome you know the the profits of the
of the cases but man that's kind of
weird like isn't it no i don't think
that so this guy's in southern
california so maybe he's in san diego so
it's a pretty big city but i think if
you look at the top 20 cities in america
if you look at the billboards it's
always personal injury uh lawyers and
there's this one guy in um
in austin in austin's like a top 15 city
maybe and he says that his earnings are
i forget exactly what it says his
earnings are but i looked him up on
instagram and he's got a collection of
like 15 ferraris he was in the newspaper
because he had a birthday party for his
daughter or for himself and he had like
rod stewart or someone crazy he spent
like three million on that and they
talked about his home and he was
donating checks for two or three million
dollars and that was in austin uh his
name was thomas i think something thomas
and
i think i know a personal injury
attorney in st louis and he's got a
mansion in miami he's got a place in st
louis where we're from i mean i think
some of these guys could
could really roll in it and be netting
10 or 20 a year yeah this is it's wild
and i like that idea of the the gym
launch for x um
i think you're right with lawyers
[Music]
you